kamala harris is much more subtle she
makes claims
that are kind of true and kind of not
but she has no real substantiation and
then she waits for people to draw
inferences from them so she's a clever
liar
right she's not an obvious liar she's a
clever liar so
how would you like to have kamala harris
as your president because again remember
i said this the day she was nominated by
nominating kamala harris joe biden
was making himself secondary to the
campaign and if the trump campaign had
not been so focused in on whatever it is
trump wanted to do that day they would
have focused in on kamala harris who is
a deeply unlikable radical
who was so bad at her job that she
dropped out of the democratic primaries
before they even hit california because
she knew she was going to get skunked in
her home state
so as president kamala harris would be
dishonest like clintonian dishonest
presumption issue would be radical
because she has been radical in her
actual voting record
and she would be deeply vicious because
she has insulted huge swaths of
americans
as racist for not supporting her for not
supporting joe biden
she is like barack obama without any of
the charm basically
so if you liked the obama administration
particularly what it did to america you
would love a harris administration
and conversely if you didn't like barack
obama's administration
if you thought that barack obama was
radical enough for you and divisive
enough for you
then get ready because kamala harris
will double down on that to the nth
degree she's a more obvious politician
she's less subtle she does not use a
stiletto she uses a machete
okay so here let's just let's walk down
memory lane with kamala harris in
preparation for the debate tonight so
you'll remember this was the moment when
we
all learned that kamala harris was
supposedly a great debater this is where
kamala harris called her running mate a
racist essentially
it was personal and it was actually very
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country
and it was not only that but
you also worked with them to oppose
busing
and you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools
and she was bussed to school every day
and that little girl was me so much
emotion in her voice and then
her campaign had a t-shirt up on her
campaign website within moment
i said by the way i said this at the
time that he was being unfairly maligned
here
that opposing federal forced busing was
not in fact the wrong policy in the
1970s nor is it wrong policy today and
kamala harris would never
in fact stand in favor of federally
forced busing but she attacked joe biden
as a racist and then of course she
backed off of it you'll remember that
kamala harris suggested that joe biden
was in fact a sexual abuser and then she
backed off of this as well right this
kind of disappeared into the ether
when when there were accusers who came
out and suggested that joe biden had
touched them inappropriately
or against their consent she said i
believe the accusers in fact
after this she even went on to say maybe
joe biden should drop out of the race
here was kamala harris way back when
i believe them and i i respect
them being able to tell their story and
having the courage to do it
do you believe that the vice president
should enter this race
oh he's gonna have to make that decision
for himself
now she was asked about this right she
has been asked about this
and her answer was i'm focusing on trump
right now and this is the answer of
every single democrat
don't let that be the answer they should
have to answer basic
questions about whether they believe
whether she believes that her running
mate
is a racist or a rapist right she ought
to have to answer
those particular questions since she
threw out there those implications
she'd overtly call him a racist all she
did was suggest that he would have
stopped little girls like her meaning
a black little girl from going to an
integrated public school that's what she
suggested on an open debate stage and
then backed off of it
she suggested that she believed the
accusers of joe biden and then she
backed off of it
she's deeply dishonest and pence should
press on this tonight
she's deeply dishonest on the issues you
have no idea where she stands
originally in the at the beginning of
the campaign she tried to hijack bernie
sanders
medicare for all shtick and then she ran
directly away from the medicare for
alshtic
in fact she told axios on hbo quote i
have to tell you honestly i knew it i
said to my team we needed to do a better
plan this is not good enough
i said to my team i know we're going to
take a political hit for it i knew that
i knew we were
i knew i'd be called a flip-flopper for
that well if you knew you were going to
be called a flip-flopper for that then
why did you embrace medicare for all in
the first place and the answer is
because she's
such a political animal and she she is
just
a chameleonic politician with tendencies
toward the radical left
harris was asked specifically for
example about the price tag of the green
new deal so she was a senate co-sponsor
of the green new deal now the green new
deal
would cost according to aoc's plan some
trillion dollars 93 trillion dollars
okay which is crazy she was asked about
the price tag of what the green news
dealer cost and she just
elided the question completely three
trillion dollars a year for medicare for
all by some studies i don't
depending on which portions of the green
new deal you picked to do first that's
money
uh that you know what the republicans
are going to say tax and spend liberals
pie in the sky
one of the things that i admire and
respect is the measurement
that is captured in three letters roi
what's the return on the investment
people in the private sector understand
this really well
it's not about a cost it's about an
investment and then the question should
be
is it worth the cost in terms of the
investment potential are we going to get
back more than we put in
okay so this is the line that biden has
been using as well and bernie sanders
which is it doesn't matter how much
money you spend on the green new deal
ever because
there will be green jobs at the end of
it just like there were shovel ready
jobs at the end of barack obama's
stimulus that never materialized
just like the green jobs are van jones
produced zero green new jobs
while he was on staff at the obama
administration
kamala harris was asked about whether
she would be in favor of packing the
supreme court she refused to answer that
question as well
so where the hell does this lady stand
on anything you don't know all you know
is her voting record which is radically
leftist
and you know her personality which is
deeply dishonest and this lady
will probably be president of the united
states if joe biden is elected here she
was
failing to explain where she stands on
expanding the supreme court
if judge barrett is confirmed and
the democrats have control of the senate
next year and the white house and the
house representatives
should the supreme court be expanded
uh you know what let's i think that
first of all joe's been very clear
that um he is going to to
pay attention to the fact and i'm with
him on this one thousand percent
pay attention to the fact that right now
lawrence people are
voting
what is that what the f is that right
now people are voting so she won't
answer whether she should pack in the
court
she won't answer green new deal
questions on cost show and answer
medicare for all
she will not answer any serious policy
question at all
same thing with joe biden they're all
just gonna point to trump and the media
will let them get away with it and so if
joe biden wins here's who will be
emboldened the radical left who have
never had to answer a simple question
the media who have dishonestly covered
for the radical left
and members as we will see of the
so-called deep state meaning
members of the regulatory bodies of the
american executive branch
who acted in terrible fashion as it
turns out in 2016
and who will be put back in positions of
power if joe biden and kamala harris
were to gain the presidency did you know
that every like on this video creates
one additional leftist tier don't ask me
why that's called science to take
advantage of this amazing opportunity
hit the like button